only on cbs this morning we spoke with
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg
about new plans to stop misinformation
ahead of election day
zuckerberg says that facebook is focused
on connecting its users with accurate
information
through a boater information center you
can see it it's at the top of every
facebook
and instagram page take a look facebook
calls it
one stop shop it connects users with
details about local election guidelines
for registration and mail and ballots
in our exclusive interview with mark
zuckerberg yesterday told us that the
tech giant will prohibit
new political ads in the week before the
election he also says the company is
preparing for potential disputes
over election results one of the things
that i'm that i'm quite worried about
after election day is that
since it may take additional time for
the votes to get counted this year
especially with mail-in voting there's a
greater chance of
civil unrest and violence after the
election you know some people expect
that there to be an answer to who won
the election on election night
i don't think we're necessarily going to
get that and i think it's important that
we
start preparing people now that there's
nothing illegitimate about taking a few
extra days or even weeks
in order to make sure that all the votes
get counted in fact it would be
illegitimate if we if we
didn't make sure that all the ballot
votes were counted so what will you do
say on election night if one candidate
says i won
when all the votes aren't in we're
putting in place of policy
we have a partnership with reuters and
if someone tries to prematurely declare
victory whether it's in a presidential
election or any of the others
before um there's a consensus on who won
that election then we're going to add
some context and a label
to that post saying um there isn't a an
official result on this election
and directing people to the voting
information center where we'll have the
list of all the official results that
have come in
do you have any concerns about campaign
ads on your platform are you thinking
about readjusting your strategy about
that
yeah so thanks for for asking about this
so one of the new policies that we're
announcing
is we're going to block new political
and issue ads
in the last week of the campaign and i
generally believe that the best antidote
to bad speech is more speech but when
there's a vote
then if someone is is kind of dumping
some new information if it's
misinformation in the last days of the
election
then there may not be time for that
normal kind of debate and process to
play out
and that's why i think it's important to
have extra restrictions
in the last week you and i have had the
conversation before about misinformation
and political ads there does seem to be
a bit of a contradiction there that
you won't challenge incorrect political
ads
but you will challenge misinformation
from candidates
you know the thing that i'm very
sensitive is having us be the ultimate
deciders
of what is right and wrong and true and
false in the world
there are a number of cases where we can
rely on other authorities
around elections we partner with local
election officials so if someone is
saying
hey don't go to this polling place
because the lines are really long
and the local election official says no
that's false it's fine here
then we'll take that down that's voter
suppression and we'll take that down no
matter who says it
this week we learned that the fbi tipped
off facebook
to russian interference on your platform
what did they point out to you that you
didn't know well
over the last few years we've put a lot
of effort into building
partnerships with the intelligence
community and election commissions
around the world as well as the other
tech companies so part of the normal
security apparatus now is that we share
intelligence and tips with each other
and between the the partnerships that we
have in place
with governments and other tech
companies we were able to
find and disrupt this relatively early
you're talking about what you're doing
on your platform to safeguard this
election but this is also a personal
cause for you and your wife priscilla
you both announced
that you were donating 300 million
dollars to do what exactly
you know there have been these recent
debates about you know funding the us
postal service and
and you know we just had a lot of
conversations about wow is there
anything that we can do to help
contribute
to making sure that all the
infrastructure is funded in the way that
it needs to be
that they had the poll workers they
needed including being able to pay
hazard pay to folks
to be able to come in but they had ppe
for all their poll workers
so we donated um 300 million dollars to
two groups um to be able to partner with
a bunch of local counties and
and state election officials to make
sure they have the resources that they
need
i've seen you all over these things i'm
curious about what keeps you up at night
i was thinking about the kenosha guard
that was an armed militia that you you
have said
you admitted that it was an operational
mistake that was using facebook to
organize
what went wrong there you know listen
the the shooter in
in in kenosha was not a member of this
group
but you did take it down after after the
incident where three people were shot
and two died by the 17 year old teenager
we've spent a long time looking into
this deeply and we've designated him as
a
mass murderer and have taken down all
his accounts through our investigation
we didn't find that there was any kind
of premeditation or anything
in his accounts that would have
suggested that um that we missed some
signal in advance
now some people did report the the group
and we made mistakes in not taking down
the group
um when those reports came in we did
take it down it did violate our policies
um but we were we were slow on that for
militia groups like this especially
ahead of this election we're going to
need to be cracking down on this
more aggressively in advance of that to
make sure that there aren't any of these
groups that could get activated after
the election
and contribute to civil unrest and he
announced
mark zuckerberg just this morning that
they're strengthening their enforcement
against
groups like that and q anon and
especially concerned about what could
happen after the election he's very very
concerned about that and i thought he
made a
really good point that just because we
don't have the results or that we may
not have results election night we don't
know that of course
that we may not have it don't think it's
not a legitimate
election well that's a that's going to
be a pivotal role for us as well
anthony he said that you know in in
telling people look just
we're used to getting the final result
election night but under the
circumstances this year we may not yeah
because covet has changed the game a lot
of people now will not be going to the
polls so a lot of people will be using
mail
i want to underscore how big a deal it
is and it's a great thing that instagram
and facebook are are giving people
voting information how to register where
to find your your
that is a great non-partisan way to help
democracy itself
yes and they've never done something
that big before and i also think that
it's worth noting that they're giving
300 million dollars of their own
personal account that is you could say
yeah they're billionaires they can
afford it but that's but
it's still three hundred million dollars
and that still isn't that amount of
money
yes it is